hi my name is andy traub and i own a
company called more profit technology
very early on in the start of my company
i stumbled upon tungle
and very quickly i found tunngle to be
the most
effective
and important tools
in my business other than having an
internet connection
because what tumble has done for me
and i am the company
within what it's done for me is it's
enabled me to multiply myself to make
myself available to so many different
people all the time
and yet still have control over my
schedule
the interface is very very simple and i
know they're always looking at ways to
improve it which i believe they're going
to do very soon they've done very
recently
and i know the leadership at tumble is
all about simplicity
and the price point you can't beat it
because it's free
and i hate to say this but
i would pay for it i really would pay
for tunngle because i know that tunngle
helps me make more money because i can
control my schedule and yet my clients
all around the world who need advising
on those things i talked about they feel
like they're in control because they get
to pick a time that works for them
so thank you tumble for making a great
product
and i look forward to seeing how you're
going to improve it and i look forward
to seeing more people integrate tungle
and their business
because it really really is the best way
to set up and organize meetings with
other people so thanks